ah sure well I come from Belarus this is
where
the first 17 years of
there I come also not from the capital
but from a very small city of miners my
entire families and mining spends a lot
of time on the ground and I was the one
who managed to have escaped so with
regards to assert Arianism of course
Belarus is known for having one leader
in place since 1995 and the political
situation there is not entirely enviable
and if you listen to some of the pundits
America that would often describe it as
the last outpost of tyranny in Europe I
started working on technology we are
indirect way I started working for a
nonprofit organization called
transitions online which was one of
those Western NGOs that was primarily
interested in promoting freedom of
expression professional journalism but
also we can say democracy and human
rights in the former Soviet Union and my
contribution to the work was to figure
out how to build a new media strategy
and of course coming from Belarus at the
very beginning I was very excited about
the potential of this new tools because
the way I would read it is that
everything else has been tried you know
we've tried NGOs we've tried political
parties we've tried you know building
nationalist movements everything in the
case of Belarus has been tried and
failed and here comes this new
technology you can use text messages to
mobilize people you can use blogs to
discuss things you cannot discuss in the
traditional media you can rely on the
power of cell phones to capture police
brutality I mean there was a lot of
excitement around 2005 2006 which partly
again derives from the political climate
in Eastern Europe at the time you had
the revolution in Serbia then you had a
few years later a revolution in Ukraine
you had the revolution before that in
Georgia something was brewing in Eastern
Europe and we had a lot of hope and I
invested a lot of hope in technology but
then I think my other cynical is the
European part took over and I have to
add that I also spent four years in
Bulgaria this is where I got educated
and Bulgaria is known as the rest of the
Balkans for its cynicism
and my cynical Bulgarian side I think
took over at some point in 2006 2007 and
I became very skeptical of the very
tools and platforms we were using in
part because I saw that they were
actually making very little difference
to the situation on the ground to people
who were on the ground using those tools
but I also noticed that the Syrian
government's themselves were actually
actively deploying those tools to spy on
the population to engage in propaganda
by paying and training bloggers to
spread the kind of truth that the
government wanted to spread by engaging
in new forms of censorship through
cyberattacks and I basically saw the
other side of this digitization and I
saw that if you leave things as they are
and we engage in this very happy
cheerful celebration of the power of the
internet you would miss the real story
and the real story unfortunately was
that certain governments were getting
empowered as well so in my own case you
know those two utopian project on the
one hand coming from me hoping that this
might change the world for the better
and at the same time a dystopian cynical
side trying to show how you know
well-meaning schemes
Oland up and disaster somehow came
together and produced my first book
which i think is entirely dependent on
my professional experience as someone
who worked for an NGO but also someone
who saw many of those early intervention
schemes on the ground to someone who
loved them Baldur's in that in the
Balkans now you know how many you know
how many times have been asked that
question on the radio I was about so my
next book is a cold to save everything
click here the folder of technological
socialism and this book is in some sense
a continuation of that
in that I'm shifting my attention away
from certain countries from a Syrian
government's and I'm looking much closer
to liberal democracies I'm trying to
understand what makes liberal
democracies work why they work as they
do politically wise they work is to do
socially and my hunch when I was
beginning to write that book was that
there is a new player in town and this
player Silicon Valley it's geeks
engineers technologists innovators who
because our world became so mediated
through technology suddenly acquired
power they are the new elite but they
are an unacknowledged to it in some
sense and I also sensed when I began
writing the book was that they're very
different from typical commercial
players they have like coca-cola
McDonald's that just wants to go and
sell you another hamburger or another
coke they actually want to change the
world and they want to change the world
for the better and all being engineers
they have their own ideas about how to
do that and they have the means they
have the tools and they are lucky in
that we tend to view any initiative that
involves technology and information is
being beneficial because somehow
interest is bias and society that as
long as you have more information things
automatically batter because you have
more knowledge it's a bias that goes all
the way back to the Enlightenment
there is no no Leela bias about
technology that technology is great for
liberating us from nature and we should
invest more power and energy into
harvesting it to you know liberate
ourselves from the burdens of the world
so in in a sense we tend to be far less
critical of them as players because we
already have existing biases about
technology and information so what I
discover it is that there is a sustained
effort in Silicon Valley you make the
world a better place and this is more or
less what I call solution ISM but to
really understand its nature you have to
see how they go about defining their
problems so part of my argument is that
Silicon Valley is now empowered
to solve problems that may not actually
exist they think that politics is bad
because there is hypocrisy in politics a
politics is bad because there is
partisanship in politics so if only we
can make everything open and transparent
if only we can make people more honest
and replace political parties was you
know direct democracy which you can now
do because we can now vote on anything
through our mobile phones right and we
can read about any things there are
mobile phones democracy will
automatically improve that's one of the
assumptions that geeks make and one of
the justifications for that assumption
is not just how to think about democracy
it's also how we think about our unique
historical situation they think that
because Wikipedia and open source
software and Google and Facebook have
succeeded we are on the edge of a new
society with entirely new rules whose
entirely new practices internally new
institutions so many of the schemes
which would look outright cookie to us
you know 10 or 15 years ago or 20 years
ago suddenly look normal because we are
prepared for the next rupture and we
have seen that rupture in the world of
Education in the world of knowledge
production and we expect that rupture
will not happen elsewhere beat politics
be the world of fighting crime be the
world of you know how scared we're now
we can actually have consumers monitor
the health and self-diagnose instead of
having them go to the doctor I mean this
is wonderful for many people in Silicon
Valley because you destroy
intermediaries no because the idea is
that when the media is a bad the flatter
the world the more easy it is for people
to live in it that's the template of
Silicon Valley and I'm trying to
challenge it because I think Hayek is
often good verticality is often good
networks are often far less effective
than hierarchies and inefficiency
ambiguity opacity hypocrisy all of those
in small doses a positive values then
advices their virtues and we need to
learn how to recognize them as virtues
and we need to celebrate them